was my father like it was like a storm
and he would show up in your life and
then he would disappear
if you've been waiting for the prison
break cast to join countless other tv
series and films reuniting for extra
episodes reboots or limited series
well i have bad news for you star
wentworth miller has
no plans to revisit his character on the
show
the 48 year old addressed rumors about a
potential
sixth season of the hit fox series in an
instagram post
revealing he's officially stepped down
from the role of michael schofield
why you may ask well because he does not
want to play
straight characters anymore writing in
part on a related note
i'm out of pb officially not because of
static
on social media although that has
centered the issue i just don't want to
play straight characters
their stories have been told and told
we're gonna get you out of here miller
came out in 2013
after playing the character on the hit
drama for four seasons from 2005
to 2009 but don't worry he knows
some die hard fans may take the news
hard adding
if you were a fan of the show and hoping
for additional seasons
i understand this is disappointing i'm
sorry
the actor also shared negative remarks
that had been left on his page
disclosing that he will be disabling
comments due to
quote the possibility of queer kids
visiting here
recently out of the closet or exploring
the idea
i don't want them exposed to bull
well i definitely cannot fault him for
that now for those fans that
really fell for michael well wentworth
has something to say about that
writing if you're hot and bothered
because you fell in love with a
fictional
straight man played by a real gay one
that's your work
you know you want it to be true losing a
brother
massive hole that leaves in your life
like the same mess of whole losing
husband next
following the actor's post his former
castmates were very quick to show their
support
including miller's on-screen brother
dominic
who responded in the comments writing it
was fun mate
what a ride it was fully support and
understand your reasoning
glad you've made this decision for your
health and for truth
keep the posts coming and miller's
former love interest on the series
wrote to all the fans know this the cast
of prison break
is a queer friendly space we stand with
and among our friends and family in the
lgbtq plus community
with full throttled support for the
rights and artistic work
all the time always and if that's a
problem for anyone
to quote a good man that's your work
i love that now prison break originally
aired for four seasons on fox
followed by a tv film the final break in
2016
and then was revived by fox for a fifth
season which aired in 2017.
rumors of a sixth season first started
back in 2018 with dominic purcell
fueling the fire on an instagram post
writing in part
rumor number three will season pb6
happen
yes and while wentworth might be done
playing straight characters
viggo morrison is defending his decision
to play a gay man
in falling looks like a goddamn girl
did they know you were a [ __ ] in the army
i didn't really know myself now the film
focuses
on john and his relationship with his
anti-gay father willis who is also
suffering from dementia
mortises not only stars as john he
penned the script
and it will also be his directorial
debut
you are such a tall and you are fansy
[Music]
i'm trying to help you dad
[Music]
kevin doesn't want him and he'll keep
sending him back in a recent interview
the 62 year old
actor said that there are certain
characters he wouldn't play
drawing the line at playing another race
but defended his decision to portray a
gay man
saying i thought what if it's not a wife
what if it's a husband i'll try that
i'll write the next scene and see how it
feels if it doesn't work or feels
somehow
not right for the story then i won't use
it but i liked it
the actor stressed that the role is not
a gimmick or a trigger adding that he
had not
initially planned on the character being
gay but was inspired to change his
sexual orientation while writing an
airport scene where jon receives a call
from his partner
so what do you think of wentworth's
decision and what are your thoughts on
vigo's defense
let me know in the comments below and as
always subscribe to et canada for more
pride
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos